all right you want it I want you guys to
still think I'm cool nobody ever thought
you were [ __ ] cool what are you
talking about now show them what you've
learned no I want to show my subscribers
that with a hard work dedication and a
solid mind and fortitude you can do
whatever you want now show them the
dream that you have in the passion that
you have for me
happy feet go sensei is upset I'm upset
don't say that no no come on
no you can't punch anymore you lost
again because I'm not strong god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
do it get get it that's all me I don't
see you doing [ __ ] my turn
no nope how GG do it how do I buddy do
it
oh that's it table helping in there
everybody I don't know anything I know
but I'm Joe who didn't even get a kid
just lesson everyone laughed at him huh
no no I was at me she said oh come on
River dancing why come on
no no come on come on come on come on
what is it's about fun and entertainment
I know but I'm not ready yet
oh that was such a sincere thing so I'll
let it go
thank you David just give up on your
dreams kids because even your idols when
they try they just don't care anymore so
I understand what you said about dance
real quick I don't know how I'm trying
to learn it you think I'm stupid I'm
stupid with that she's pointing right at
me they don't want to got you come on do
it do it oh yeah yeah I want to join in
on this dance lesson I'm accused a
little [ __ ] elbow elbow is is it enough
the ended and push your arm doing okay
hey jacket
come on everybody was dancing with you
good
I am always I want you to be my hero
you're my older sister you're supposed
to fight everyone together yeah well I
want you to do it just because I like
what you're doing I think the message
that you're sending out is amazing so
you can't just do it by words and
Instagram you have to do it and show it
huh I'll help you with the feet that's
the whole point I like what I like the
message and the positivity behind it and
it's amazing yeah yeah then okay okay
ready 1 2 3
rock'n'roll it's supposed to be hard
yay finally we got Gio to do the bed
high-five good one nice we are [ __ ] oh
girl oh [ __ ] yo girl what ah [ __ ] yo
girl
what i [ __ ] your girls ah [ __ ] you
girl [ __ ] your girl in the cash in the
ass in the ass how many times I [ __ ]
your girl 2 times 2 times 1
how many times I [ __ ] your girl photon
[ __ ] out her [ __ ] busted I said her
[ __ ] busted and now her face busted cuz
I stuck my dick up in her mouth like
the last to last another world did I
write to take it David that wasn't it
your heart is that's a light punch I can
tell you're real gonna tell me what you
are I think you could do it I'm just
curious
no I don't want kidding wrong who does
see you feel hurt no that's good
you have a soft side you can but you
have to do this side now cuz for hurts
but tomorrow it's gonna be this huge
well but oh oh god damn it why did you
make me do this to you I didn't want to
do this she's doing this with the police
I because I was in [ __ ] police report
he doesn't even feel that he wants ideas
are no I'm doing a decimal bath no I
don't want to do why are you why are you
sacrificing functions I'm not doing it
ever again if you want the footage get
it from David I'm not doing it ever
again I'm never hitting you again but
you only hit me like a 20 percent I'm
yet I need suction to a patient do when
you get mad you'll never heard of it
walking with them big feet you always
heard a noise squeezing them but never
like that never to hurt him a punch is
enough you just choked me haha anyways
can hurt you a bunch is nothing but just
a little bit you punch him no you know
for suggest that everyone gathers
forgive me if I'm touching and I'm
squeezing used to catching and release
and thinking by instead of leasing it
obsession happening it's happening with
the pips the gridlock I like it hot I
think one of the dope things about being
a part of JK news is that you get to
work and mind you we work hard we shoot
for like what 10 12 plus hours you know
it's fun you get to be with your friends
and you know it's a creative space
because everybody here is like an artist
and they have like that weird type of
mind there's no judgment you do or the
[ __ ] you month stuff that you were doing
when you were a kid you still do today
it's fun man JK news lb birthday go
mother to him tell me give me things
like this tonight spinning right off
their patron talking close it up sick
kids so who's your girlfriend please
Timmy where y'all going don't you hop
over get